benvenuti sassari oggi è il compleanno
livelli
[Applauso]
da berlino e compie un anno
allora ora lo vedete stanchissimo perché
stamattina a vita aveva portato a fare
il bagnetto e in più gli ho anche fatto
fare no poi si giochino lunghissima di
mezz'ora quindi è già stanco
ora andremo al negozi di animali e
andremo a comprare il suo gioco
preferito che in pratica era un gioco
che avete già visto ma lui sa di tutto
ed è il blocchetto sonoro come la faceva
proprio le sue canzoni con quel
brocchetto finché non l'ha distrutto del
tutto esami
comunque siccome il suo compleanno
andiamo a rifondare lo sarà super
contento e poi vediamo anche se c'è
qualcos'altro per lui io li festeggeremo
avuto il suo compleanno di noi a schiave
stories stabili assieme a merlino che
adesso a tanti l'estate un mi piace se
volete vedere altri blog
altri video con berlino e ora andiamo
subito negozi di animali vediamo cosa
vuole merlino per il suo compleanno
diamo il 68 prefetto de martino
[Musica]
certo lo ricordi mirino dello scooter
il pacchetto rilassa parametri attaccano
siamo tornati
abbiamo comprato il gioco preferito di
merlino il blocchetto poi abbiamo preso
cappellino va compleanno un nuovo torino
è una specie di forza di compleanno
biscotto di auguri e la candelina
quindi per prima cosa ora vediamo la
candelina nell'attesa di compleanno
biscotto per cani per merlino così potrà
assaggiarla in cui viviamo il regalino
[Applauso]
ferreyra felicissimo perché carina
aspetto berlino dove la casellina
aspetta altro che candela la pancia
tutte festa ma mi sembra che gli piace
tantissimo per con strass grano
accendiamo la candelina parlerò
mi sa che non gli interessa proprio la
candelina berlino medaille un pezzo da
maggio tutto io grana pianto il bambino
tutto tantissimo nelle prospettive di
berlino si porta a porta
prima di tutto la tavola adesso mr maxi
cappello ma che bontà
il silenzio
mamma mia che belle che bella torta di
compleanno tutto nove di tutto noi li
facciamo monte sole lunghezze no
potrebbe fargli male con questo io a
nascondermi dietro o speriamo che non
siano già sognando nascondere scappano
anche questo allora togliamo gli questo
cappellino intanto
che buono tutto maggio tutto è arrivato
il momento del regalo di compleanno me
la stavo per dargli il regalo ma lui sta
ancora cercando la brava subito aprendo
la crisi la nona skoda anche parchetto è
il regalo di merlino e come ho spiegato
prima questo era il suo gioco preferito
chi se lo ricorda
e in pratica luci suonava proprio le
canzoncine schiacciando questo il
blocchetto pick up and roll ha distrutto
in tremila pezzettini in tipo 2 o 3 mesi
l'ha distrutto e durata e ora ora starà
pensando ma come è possibile che è
tornato ecco a tolto la confezione
vediamo come reagisce berlino non si può
credere che è tornato in vita il suv che
lo mangio tra l'altro c'era anche la
vela e la mela e il cibo preferito in
assoluto di berlino non so perché non
fanno melina melino vediamo
schietto adesso suona qualcosa forse si
deve ancora ricordare che certi schietto
lì a berlino è già riuscito a togliere
il bruco dalla mela e si è preso lamela
è stato carino non si va già quella è
non è una vela di quelle che budget ue
scrivete nei commenti secondo voi quanto
durerà il nuovo bruttino il gioco
preferito di merlino anche rima con i
merli in ostaggio distruggendo la mela
merlino piccola verde che marino guarda
il resto della torcia io ti do il
cappello il cappello di buon compleanno
de tomi della torta l'ha fatta a dormire
ti piace
mi interessano minuti credo che faccia
famelica nel mio marito malato mentale
di tutto perché così non me lo lascio un
pezzo da facciamo tutto dai berlin
aspettiamo la cabina ha detto spegniamo
la candelina
oggi è arrivato il momento di cantare
con server l'ipla tanti amori e tanti
anni
[Musica]
[Applauso]
berlino e di grandissimo nonno nell'età
dei cani se non sbaglio corrisponde a 7
anni quindi berlino è ancora un piccolo
un piccolo bimbo cuccioletto sette anni
è morto a chi ce li vedete io volevo
ringraziarvi per averci sempre seguito
per aver seguito berlino mentre cresceva
vi siete affezionati tantissimo anche
voi li volete un sacco bene come gliene
vogliamo noi ringraziamo tantissimo
scriveteci nei commenti se avete degli
animali come si chiamano quanti anni a
macomer linea iniziato a suonare bruca
giocando questo giochino preferito è
troppo contento
devi germont clil ovvero la 4 castelli
che su quel che significa riproducono i
nostri altri video cliccate su quello
che preferite e buona visione
[Musica]